[Music]
[Applause]
sure is
the cbs college basketball analyst and a
man who had the nickname
special k when he was in high school
clark how
are you today d.p always good to check
in with you i'm doing well and i trust
that you could say the same
uh when's the last time you were called
special k
yes the other day they called me that in
the studio quite a bit
as a matter of fact um seth calls me
that
there's some other folks that are part
of our behind the scenes broadcast team
that help us
look good and sound good they refer to
me as that some of my
golfing buddies will throw that out if
i'm not in their pocket
[Laughter]
but yeah i hear it on occasion yeah so
i'm kind of a natural connector having
the last name kellogg and
distinguishing myself a little bit and
the hardwood in my days of playing
yeah now you scored 50 in the state
championship game 51
in ohio is that is that record still did
that still stand
yeah it does it was in the championship
game and actually it's um
interesting you mentioned that we um
just had the sad news i played against
granville waiters in that game and
he was my roommate in college at ohio
state and we just got word um a few days
ago that he
uh sadly passed um kovic complications
are suspected but
he always had that up on me that one leg
because
i have the state championship single
game record
and he got the trophy because they beat
us in that game and
as much as we loved each other he would
always jab me
about that on occasion so that's one of
my fond memories of
my former roommate and good friend but
yeah i still have they only get one
chance a year dan
go after that and you got to be in the
end you got to be in the championship
game i mean it was a championship game
record so
they only get one shot at it and a
couple of guys have come close but
so far it's um still standing but as you
know
just about all records are meant to be
broken and eventually that won't applaud
too i'm sure
and when you went to the indiana pacers
out of ohio state
uh do you remember your welcome to the
nba moment
as a rookie yeah i do i do it was um
it was spencer haywood
he was playing i think it was for the
wizards and he
he occasionally brings this up when i
bump into him but um
he was a veteran near the end
unbelievable player i remember
reading about him and then watch him a
little bit in his prime and then he
but he was near the back side of his
career but he was still a wily veteran
and i think i shot like two for 18.
and he was in my ear the whole time and
the other thing he did to me which i
never forgot
i was trying to deny him as he went
across the lane
trying to get to the post and i had my
arm out away from my body
and i tried to deny him he locked my
arm and dragged me in front of the
official and screamed
and guess who got the foul you did well
he was a grown
it man at me after he did it he chuckled
uh your first game against michael
jordan
you you had you had a great game your
first game
right i played well i mean at that time
you know the pacers weren't playing if
we were we were struggling the bulls
were
not where they would get to as a
championship so that team so that was a
team
a couple of teams cleveland the bulls
that were kind of we felt on our level
we were all in transition
trying to build something and deal with
milwaukee and the bucks
the bucks and the sixers and the cell
trying to get to that level
and so yeah we always felt like we
compete and actually in my first couple
of years
i think we pretty much split our games
and i typically performed if i recall
correctly you know that's
almost out of my rear actually it is out
of my rearview mirror i can't even see
that
well i got jordan had 27 this is his
first week in the nba you had 31 jordan
had 27. so you owned michael jordan
no no no there you go
there you go reese's trying to connect
dots that aren't close to them okay
okay all right my bad my bad yeah
definitely
i thought you i thought you owned him my
bad
we're talking to clark kellogg cbs
sports college basketball
analyst studio analyst is it easier to
explain
what happened with the pac-12 or what
didn't happen with the big ten
i think you can go either way on that
that's two sides of the same coin man i
you know we have this conversation on
occasion in basketball circles a really
good
conference regular season does not port
10
for a great tournament season for the
conference
you play teams in the tournament you
play against your
conference opponents in the conference
so the big ten and big 12
clearly based on how those teams
performed during
the regular season were arguably the two
best leagues in the country
i don't think there's any denying or
debating that
once the tournament starts unless you
play against
all big ten opponents as the pac-12 and
there were a couple of
there was a woodshed from oregon on iowa
there was a win
ucla over michigan state and i don't
know if there were any other
inter-conference collisions between the
pac-12
and big ten yeah i don't think so so
that said clearly the pac-12 has had a
remarkable
run during the tournament those teams
were
good and inconsistent for different
reasons but fermented nicely
and played and then you get oregon state
that's been outstanding
and it's two wins to get to this point
not to mention
rolling through the pac-12 tournament in
a in a tournament they had to win to be
on this stage so
uh kudos to the pac-12 i mean clearly
they've had a remarkable run in the
tournament but it doesn't dismiss
the quality of play during the regular
season for the big ten it's unfortunate
that
it wasn't able to be validated during
this time of year
you know it almost feels like they're
two top heavy teams it's baylor and
gonza
it's gonzaga and then baylor and then it
feels like we take a little bit of a
step down
with michigan because they don't have
one of their better players
um do you see it that way that it's it's
real
yeah yeah i do i do do yeah i've
actually felt that way i mean baylor had
a bit of a
snag and speed bump after coming out of
an extended pause and their pause was a
little different than the pause that
michigan had where michigan came out
after a couple of weeks off and played
really well because none of their
players actually had contracted the
virus whereas baylor's players actually
a few of them had gotten sick
so there was a difference in their
recovery and now that they've had the
benefit of some time together they're
healthier
and so forth they showed another level
of what they showed
pretty much during the early season and
regular season i mean that's an elite
defensive team with a quartet of guards
that can do everything you want guards
to do at both ends of the floor pressure
the ball
help out dig down on the post make
threes dribble drive to create shots for
other people dribble drive to finish for
themselves i mean there's no weakness
with their four guards and that's where
it intrigues me if in fact both advanced
gonzaga and baylor if they were to match
up
then that would be one that would uh be
really interesting to watch
could baylor disrupt gonzaga in the
backcourt i don't see it
i don't think there's another team out
there that could uh
so i've got zags winning it all have had
them in that position
since probably midway through the season
um baylor would be my second choice and
i think the winner of the michigan
florida state game
would be the next team i would look at
usc is intriguing if they advance dan
because they can defend
they've got size up front and good
perimeter defenders
um and then after that i'm not enamored
with anybody else and um that doesn't
mean i'm right but i just wouldn't be
i wouldn't have great conviction when
picking the remaining any of the
remaining teams to
to beat gonzaga uh this just in texas
coach shock shaka's smart is headed to
marquette
according to jeff goodman is this a
preemptive move of
i'll leave before i get fired wow
jump before they push i don't know i
don't know but um
interesting yeah well the carousel
starts you know there are a number of
spots that are open
and um new leadership in different
places all of that
lends to change and transition and so
yeah that was a tough way for um that
was actually one of the more painful
things to watch
and just as a fan of shaka's to see
that loss and then the way he took it
was just um it was it was it was hard
but that's part of the
the the agony of defeat um that's why
it's called
madness clark it's called exactly right
that's exactly right
um one more item here uh porter moser
has been great at loyola he's been
here before at what point do
you jump from loyola to take another job
um or do you get to a point where almost
like mark few at gonzaga
you realize that that person wants to
stay in that location well you took the
thought right out of my head i mean
that's always a personal call then
unless you're up close to somebody and
know kind of
where they are in life season and cycle
what pushes their buttons what motivates
them what's on the horizon they'd like
to grab hold of
you know fit is important success is
important but
each individual has to make that call
for themselves and obviously mark has
decided that
the things that gonzaga offers him and
competitiveness and opportunity
and lifestyle and all of that is more
important than any offers he got
in the past i don't know how that plays
out for porter moser but
that's a question you know george rather
has a quote that says
the the greatest battle of your life
will always be you
versus you and so you have to be willing
to determine what it is you
you seek and desire and if it's out
there and you want to pursue it go after
it if not
be okay with um staying put so i don't
know how it's going to play out but i
love watching that team play
and i love how he coaches so he'll have
an opportunity to keep doing it for as
long as he'd like to in my opinion
have fun tomorrow play nice and always
great to go uh catch up with you clark
thank you yeah
love you dan thank you man take care
healthy and safe buddy that's clark
kellogg
cbs sports